- [Instructor] A particle
moves along the x-axis.
The function x of t gives
the particle's position
at any time t is greater
than or equal to zero,
and they give us x of t right over here.
What is the particle's velocity
v of t at t is equal to two?
So pause this video, see
if you can figure that out.
Well, the key thing to
realize is that your velocity
as a function of time is
the derivative of position.
And so this is going to be equal to,
we just take the derivative
with respect to t up here.
So derivative of t to the third
with respect to t is three t squared.
If that's unfamiliar,
I encourage you to review the power rule.
The derivative of negative four t squared
with respect to t is negative eight t.
And derivative of three t with
respect to t is plus three.
Derivative of a constant doesn't change
with respect to time, so that's just zero.
And so here we have velocity
as a function of time.
And so if we want to know our
velocity at time t equals two,
we just substitute two
wherever we see the t's.
So it's gonna be three times four,
three times two squared,
so it's 12 minus eight
times two, minus 16,
plus three, which is
equal to negative one.
And you might say negative one
by itself doesn't sound like a velocity.
Well, if they gave us
units, if they told us
that x was in meters and
that t was in seconds,
well, then x would be,
well, I already said would be in meters,
and velocity would be negative
one meters per second.
You might also be saying,
well, what does the negative means?
Well, that means that we
are moving to the left.
Remember, we're moving along the x-axis.
So if our velocity's negative,
that means that x is decreasing
or we're moving to the left.
What is the particle's acceleration a of t
at t equals three?
So pause this video again,
and see if you can do that.
Well, here the realization is
that acceleration is a function of time.
It's just the derivative of velocity,
which is the second
derivative of our position,
which is just going to be equal to
the derivative of this right over here.
And so I'm just going to get
derivative of three t squared
with respect to t is six t.
Derivative of negative eight t
with respect to t is minus eight.
And derivative of a constant is zero.
So it's just going to
be six t minus eight.
So our acceleration at time t equals three
is going to be six times three,
which is 18, minus eight,
so minus eight, which is going
to be equal to positive 10.
All right, now they ask
us what is the direction
of the particle's motion at t equals two?
Well, I already talked about
this, but pause this video and
see if you can answer that yourself.
Well, we've already looked
at the sign right over here.
The fact that we have a
negative sign on our velocity
means we are moving towards the left.
So I'll fill that in right over there.
At t equals three, is the particle's speed
increasing, decreasing, or neither?
So pause this video,
and try to answer that.
All right, now we have
to be very careful here.
If it says is the particle's velocity
increasing, decreasing, or neither,
then we would just have to
look at the acceleration.
We see that the acceleration is positive,
and so we know that the
velocity is increasing.
But here they're not saying
velocity, they're saying speed.
And just as a reminder, speed
is the magnitude of velocity.
So, for example, at time t equals two,
our velocity is negative one.
If the units were meters and second,
it would be negative
one meters per second.
But our speed would just
be one meter per second.
Speed, you're not talking
about the direction,
so you would not have that sign there.
And so in order to figure out
if the speed is increasing
or decreasing or neither,
if the acceleration is positive
and the velocity is positive,
that means the magnitude of
your velocity is increasing.
So that means your speed is increasing.
If your velocity is negative
and your acceleration is also negative,
that also means that
your speed is increasing.
But if your velocity and
acceleration have different signs,
well, that means that
your speed is decreasing.
The magnitude of your
velocity would become less.
So let's look at our velocity
at time t equals three.
Our velocity at time three, we
just go back right over here,
it's going to be three times nine,
which is 27, three times three squared,
minus 24
plus three,
plus three.
So this is going to be equal to six.
So our velocity and acceleration are both,
you could say, in the same direction.
They are both positive.
And so our velocity's only
going to become more positive,
or the magnitude of our velocity
is only going to increase.
So our speed is increasing.
If our velocity was
negative at time t equals three,
then our speed would be decreasing
because our acceleration
and velocity would be going
in different directions.